hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
borosch nice to see you all
and we're returning with a bit more
about a rockport
i'm pretty sure most of you know
rockport raise your hand if you are
a board fan or you know him
whoa
so many hands not raised
even though he just qualified for the
world championship candidates so
but don't worry about it you go i do
think you're gonna see him he's not
gonna play the american cup but he's
definitely going to be here i believe
for uh sink field and all these rapid
blitz events
so as all you may have known the grand
chess tour is starting and it's gonna
feature him
um
so the reason we're sort of looking
through
his games because he is not just the top
player but also a prodigy of his time he
became a grandmaster at age 13 and 11
months
so very young
and
we're looking at games that he played
around that time
which
is exciting because you'll see that
even though he already was a very strong
player but i mean he still had to get
the title so he didn't they never just
gave it to him on a silver plate so
i talked about this last time
but
this is the second time so we're gonna
take a look at this one and uh i want
you guys to think about this position
a little bit
and
black is actually rapport with julie
playing a white
so
in general
um
obviously you're free to suggest moves
but it's best to evaluate first
because then you'll actually get an
understanding of the position so if you
have a question if you have a thought
chat or anyone here
thought about the position
you can even suggest moves but it's even
more beneficial
you start
thinking about
these positions in broader terms so more
general stuff and then from the broader
range you can go go to smaller ones
so uh yeah
again
black is the one playing here and just a
fair warning it's not like beef proof
your winning is black but uh he's gonna
go that direction
yeah go ahead what is your first
training
so this is on the st louis chess club
um
but you can also find it on chessverb
sometimes
but
mostly saying this chess club so
all right
so
but again if you want to um you know
speak up here that's also completely
fine
so
i'll start and i think it's uh
it's
interesting to in general talk about
in this position
white has a very very strong piece and
that strong piece is on e5
this e5 knight is very strong so one of
the big things that you sort of
understand
in chess is it's not just you who has
good pieces but your opponent so this
knight on e5 is sort of a torn in our
position
which also attacks this pawn on c6 and
there's some pressure
over there so that's one little problem
we have
now even though we have that what are
the positives that we have in this
position
there are certain positives
apart from that negative of having to
deal with that e5 knight
yeah they've got a very very nice knight
on e4 so it sort of compensates there's
a good and there's a bad
um now
overall that would just mean the
position is dynamic
but
you will have to sort of deal
with threats and maybe
even consider
of devising threats of your own
now in general this is a closed position
so the fact that we have this bishop is
not really to our
advantage it's
it's not that
it's necessarily bad because it always
attacks a strong piece
but
if we could have a knight instead we'd
probably choose that
all right so
we talked about the fact that this
knight on e5 is strong
we talked about those two nights being
pretty good what about the state of the
kings
whose king is better
white or black yeah good
uh
so this king is not as safe
and the reason is
that richie
actually has moved all these pawns pawns
that i call guardian pawns they're there
to protect your king they're not
necessarily there to use as attackers
however
richie sort of has a different mindset
he tries to go all in and in this case
it is justified
because there's no easy way to get close
to that king on g7
but normally speaking you wouldn't want
to
move away these pawns because you can
see that this king
is susceptible from any kind of attacks
either from the diagonal
sideways or frontally
thankfully the position is closed and
that is actually those minor details
that some players sort of forget
that yes
traditionally in any position
if your king is opened up you're worse
because it's going to be easily
accessible however here there is no easy
way to go and attack that king
all right so i think we kind of
spent a little bit of time understanding
the position
and now we've got to consider moves for
rockport
we already know we kind of know who has
the safer king you already know um
what should black be careful with so now
we have to think about direct threats
and threats that we may or
may want to set up
this is why you always want to simplify
and trade down well not necessarily
for example the more we would start
trading here for example if we take here
right away pawn takes
guess what's happening you're trading
but this knight that never really had an
access to this d4 square
suddenly is going to jump over
and start attacking us you'd move this
pawn well there's another weakness you
could go after that one
so every little move you make
every little step you take that knight
will be watching you
and it's going to get ugly quickly
so
trades aren't necessarily good
what grand masters and by now we can
call rapport super grand master
is all about timing
taking on e5 is by no means bad but you
want to do it at the right time
so
how many of you would want to play
either c5 or h4 let's go one by one who
would want to play c5 show your hands if
you would want to play c5 here
not an excited crowd okay that's that's
a maybe
okay
how about h4
any excited people for h4 you can't do
maybe again let's it's either yes or no
oh my god so many maybes
well you know in chess
you can just go maybe which is kind of
funny because fisher did this maybe
he kind of made a move against the world
champion mihal tal and he was like
looked over and looked
it was i think a long range move so he
could still move the bishop anywhere
so he was like oh you like this one you
like this move
and just looked at me tall quizzically
and then miho tal was wondering
stood up
shared the laugh
and then
fisher decided okay i'm not going to
play that move he's laughing at my move
he's laughing at me
and he didn't make it it turned out to
be a good one the move that he wanted to
play
but
and his memories tal said that
i was sweating
profusely when fisher was trying to make
that move
but was wondering hmm
what can i do to unsettle him so
he decided okay i'm gonna stand up i'm
not i'm gonna be stone-faced i'm not
gonna give away any secrets there gonna
share a laugh with petrossian who was a
world champion an extra champion
and
sort of
kind of
put the seed of doubt
in bobby's heart so he didn't play the
move and by the way that was a very very
important and sharp game
which tall won
and uh because he won that and the
games afterwards he became a world
championship challenger challenged miha
botwinik and what was the end result
anyone
tall one obviously
so
does psychology matter well maybe not
for bobby fischer but it didn't matter
for tao
so
in this case in this position coming
back to the position
we could
uh go on and say maybe but chess is
partly about confidence and believing in
your own moves
now
we can go kind of maybe on h4 maybe on
c5 but the real question is
what are these moves trying to
accomplish in the first place what is h4
trying to do what is c5 trying to do
so let's go one by one because that is
kind of the right way of approaching
chess you're sort of wondering okay
c5
what's what's
what's so good about c5
mean yeah go ahead
so if you go c5
you're sort of under mining
this knight so is this a dum-dum move no
it's completely fine what's wrong with
c5 there's nothing wrong with c5 there
then of course as you're saying they
can't stick because now we overwhelmed
us knight
so usually the defenders have to be the
same count here we've got two attackers
only a single knight defending
so two to one
[Music]
done deal we win because we take here
take here take here
however apart from c5 what is c5 trying
to accomplish
you know there's a good point in chat
saying both are palm breaks however
you sort of have to
find that differentiates the moves
why well eventually chess is about
making decisions
so think well this looks exactly like
the other one
even it's like meeting twin sisters
eventually you'll have to decide what's
the difference between the two right
otherwise how are you going to
differentiate
c4
okay
so
we might want to just gain some space on
the queen side
does it make any sense for us to take on
d4 though
i want some heavy reactions yes
no
no why not
um
because
they could just take back and they still
have defending on that night yes very
good
so here if we take
pawn takes back and it's kind of
replenished
uh like a shark's teeth just gets
replenished there and it's still one
two
one two attacking
same amount of attackers same amount of
defenders voila everyone's happy except
the attackers
so
that's what we know about c5
what about h4
can we say about h4
yeah you're trying to attack
so what is the difference between these
two though
yeah survivor night you have a good
point you don't necessarily want to open
up the position
but
it still kind of begs the question
which way you want to play you want to
play h4 you want to go c5
one opens the king side
where you want to attack
and the other one
leads to all those rings and whoever
owns all those rings controls the world
true story
talking about controlling
c4
you mean c5
okay
so what kind of pushes you to play c5
instead of h4
they don't have to take this
well what is h4 doing though
so do we have actually enough attackers
on the g pawn
yeah so we actually have plenty of
threats because again
believe it or not some simple math
is good to have when you're playing
chess because here we do have two
attackers and only one little defender
so that will force our opponent's hands
i'm sort of giving it away in a sense so
yeah
um don't have to take
why not
they can play any other move
okay well
tell me what move they would play this
pawn is hanging
yeah they would probably take but they
always they just don't have to
because well i am threatening to take
you
yeah
and you get the you get the point
because um you take
after if they just do nothing you take
the pawn and then they take and you
stick with your knight
yeah that's correct
so they would probably take here
yeah that's what happened
by the way
what if white takes here
saying okay
you'll take my pawn i'll take yours
i guess we're going to capture right
politics
so i heard plenty of suggestions here
here
here
which one is it
so we've got this
this
this clean h6
by the way i do have to complement uh
the first row here
that you are actually adding up some
options because a lot of times people
just say up i saw bishop takes g3 oh i'm
gonna i'm gonna play bishop take g
whatever happens i'm gonna take the pawn
but the best way of thinking
is just to have a handful of solutions
do you guys know how is it called to
have more than one solution at hand
and of course everyone is free to tell
me
how that is called
otherwise i'm gonna say it
this will not like two solutions
um
yeah
and more well it's not necessarily two
solutions
it could be two or more
yeah we're looking for like a
specific uh one
specific name for it
it's called candidate moves
so famously
now
famously there is a book
it's a very old book by kotov that
says you should look for more than a
single solution now
people can overdo this so what i would
say
is
if possible go
maximum three but
you can go for four
but there is like a little bit of a
trick here if you start considering
everything you're gonna run out of time
and even super gms run out of time
because they consider everything
but your goal should be to keep it down
to three
ideally too but sometimes it's
complicated here
i want to know which one of uh the moves
you guys would want to play here
rook h1 knight g3 bishop g3 or queen h6
so
the hard part about chess
that you have to choose
chess would be the best game ever if i
could say oh
i sorry i'm not i didn't want to take on
g3 i wanted to play something else
you can only play one once you hit the
clock it's on the board you can't change
it
so you would go queen h6 okay
so i'll be curious what you think which
one you would choose
so do tell me which one would you choose
okay
an age six okay
anyone else stick by rook h1 or queen h
really see
you got convinced how did they convince
you
they looked at all the candidate moves
oh
that's how
so
for example
we have this urge especially when we
play quick chess
to just capture our tempo go ahead
go ahead
i just stretching okay so
we have this urge of capturing
immediately and oftentimes taking
doesn't necessarily mean it's the best
move it's an option but it's not the
best necessarily
and danny actually pointed out correctly
well wait a second wait a second
what if i don't slap this pawn
and go rook h1 check
and if you take here
take here well white's position is not
rock solid anymore
because you lose your queen
so this is a very very nice point by
dany
however i do have to command the first
row over here
queen 86 is even better
this is what we call the silent move
like a silent
little sneaky move queen h1 is checkmate
and as far as i know
that ends the game so queen h1 is kind
of deadly
so if you go here well there goes the
lady
again
and it's an even more fair trade for
black
because we actually get to win the queen
for a single night
so h4
pawn takes
this was the game
now
we are going to
switch back to the game itself shortly
but there's still a couple of critical
moments that i want us to solve
so it did take they are not too excited
about us opening up the h file
so we just got to be rude here
so we we want to get it and we have to
find a way to pass on through
so this is an idea for sure
maybe if you um
take the
oh so you take
and what is your future plan
so trying to promote it i get it so
you'd push
but if you push again i might not even
take you i just block
oh yeah
so we've got the ideas of going here
or take
is there anything else
very good so um you always have to
make sure you're looking for the
absolute best move for your opponent
because then you get an objective
evaluation of the position if you're
just saying oh they're gonna blunder
their queen and oh
my goodness it's going to be a vacation
playing this game
that's not really how you ought to play
it because probably they don't want to
lose their queen so they'll do their
absolute best
so she can continue on
so queen h6
unfortunately it does feel that i can go
g3 and
what can we do
yes
what's the point of g4 it's a great move
so we go g4
it chases away the knight immediately
so white really doesn't have time to
have pawn g3 because we just captured
so white has to go somewhere in the
knight now black decides to go in knight
g5 which is a very very creative move
and somewhat uh
aggressive too
yeah always expect the opponent to play
the best sometimes they make mistakes i
mean that's part of the game
but you always have to
sort of look for the best sequence of
moves for each side
and whenever you start having that
mindset even the mindset will make you
become a better player
so of course we can't take here now
because our queen is hanging
what's the idea
um
very good that's what was played queen
h6
um one of the things that
make these gm's or super gms so good
is that there is a flow to their play
it's not just moves that are good
separately
but
it's just sequential
so
look at this
h5
h4
takes idea wants to open up the file g4
wants to do the same thing knight g5
queen h6 now it looks a little bit
straightforward that's not always the
case but i do like the method and i
think it's something worth following
try to choose a plan and follow through
no matter what
why well if you try to follow through
you're going to learn what you're really
really good at and what you need to
actually
try to solve
and here white actually took on e4
so a lot of times that's the way to
improve
is to give yourself a chance to prove
that you're very very good at
calculating these very critical lines
and if you're not
that's not necessarily a bad thing then
you know what you have to improve upon
if you go queen h4 can't i just move my
knight to g3
okay
go on
what would i play then
okay so knight e4 queen h4 my g3
queen h2
here
here
takes bye-bye right
correct
so this was played
spectacularly by rapport
queen takes h4 now knight g3 wasn't
played but there's a lot of things that
happen under the surface of a chess game
there are brilliant ideas
that is not shown on the chess board
one of them is this one here the fact
that knight g3 which is a critical move
this is the move that would be absolute
best
loses to check
here
queen h1 check
takes rook takes h1 and even though
our lady went on a vacation
well so does the king on f1 because all
these pawns and the lady is blocking the
way out and technically this is a back
rank mate
which is kind of cute so
it sort of shows
that
doing some tactics is useful
and oftentimes will help you find these
very nice little ideas all right so
we're gonna revert back from where he
got this position
and i think this will be useful but more
about that in a moment
so let's go from here
let's go from this position let me flip
the board
so
this looks like a very tame position
however rob port realizes that hey
you've got one good piece that is that
bishop on h4 so i'm going to go in that
h5 and trade it off
it takes uh well if takes takes it
jumped obviously
all right we have to
fast forward a bit knight h5
so
a lot of times
when you're sort of trying to get out of
the
middle game or from the opening to the
middle game rather
you are always wondering what is the
best piece your opponent has rapport
realizes that bishop is actually pretty
strong so it goes knight h5 not an ideal
square for the knight but it takes away
all the escaped squares from the bishop
and he will be able to trade it off
after
so bishop g3 knight takes g3
pawn takes bishop d6
already kind of the semblance of what
we're going to see towards the end
the bishop is setting up threats on that
side now
a little bit of middle game
understanding
but first off do we know the name of
this structure
well it is a queen spawn but
it's a specific one within the queen's
pawn
it is the carlsbad variation and the
cosmet variation
is very well known
for
one very specific idea and strategic
plan
and that is the minority attack so white
usually goes rupee one b4 b5 and trying
to blast open black's queen side now it
has this legendary status but it's not
like the end of the world currently this
position is sort of evaluated as either
balanced or just a slight bit better for
white
not even necessarily this one because in
this case black managed to trade off
this bishop on h4
so b1
standard plan now this is one of those
things
i heavily advise if you're trying to
improve your game
look up carol's bad
look at some games
wherever you look at it and
just play some play those positions and
have a feel
because most of the times people are
training their tactics but they don't
train strategy
rook b1
queen e7 so the fight
sort of revolves
around these critical squares
and of letting y playing b4 even if they
get b4 in that's not going to be the end
of the world
a3 a5 see so rapport is making it way
more difficult
for julie to actually break through with
b4 because if you do
that would be costing you a pawn i got
one
two
three attacking and you got only one two
defending one of those things that
actually
kind of um
surprises people
is the pawn itself is not defending
itself but hey
it's just two defenders
right now we are
white here
so knight h4
queen e6 just moving out of the way of
knight f5
rookie one
and
first off whenever you look at a
position you always have to wonder hmm
my opponent played knight h4 he kind of
knew why
why play knight h words because of
knight f5 and ideas such as this
but why did white go rook fe one
was the reason why i played rookie one
i wants to activate
to activate the rook
but is it devoid of plans or does it
have an idea behind it
yes
so once you understand
what white is trying to do it's much
easier to find your own move
f5
report just stops this plan of breaking
with e4
and even though it's not as exciting
necessarily to
play chess this way but if you
understand your opponent's plans
it's much easier to control the game f5
is a controlling move it takes away a
critical square and hinders white's
plans
queen b3
b5 now b5 shows rapport's understanding
if you look at this
and you're just new to chess
i'd be frowned or be very upset if you
play b5
why is this move so bad or at least at
first like
well it leaves this pawn on c6
completely defenseless
however
rapport says
eventually i'm actually going to get a
foreign and if my knight gets to c4
this won't be a weakness that you can
attack
in fact that reminds me of this story by
yoster um
all of you
must have known
him before yasser was the second of
victor korchnoy
and
in a similar position courchnoy
showing
a position where there was a weakness
said oh
yes you're responding hey that's a pawn
i might take that pawn
and victor famously said well it's only
a weakness if you're able to attack it
you only won't get the chance to go
after that bomb so a4
that's the reason actually white goes a4
here let's say if white plays knight f3
just bringing the knight back to a much
better square
black would go a4 himself
queen to c2 and then black is going to
actually create a beautiful apples for
that knight
and even if you think you're going to
have that time to attack it it's a
little bit too late i'm going to jump on
c4
now this plan doesn't always work
if this a4 idea and this a3 pawn isn't
there because there is this b3 break
here that doesn't really work
because for one i can capture for two
knight takes a3 is going to be a double
attack
but from a strategical standpoint i can
just take on b3 and this knight is a
monster over there you can you can't
touch that
that knight is just dominating and black
is just clearly better
for that reason y plays a4
b4 knight e2 g5 now
in general as i said earlier and i'm
going to say it again because it's very
important
you do not want to push these pawns
unless your name is richard rapport then
i forgive you you're forgiven
you know what you're doing but joking
aside
this move only makes sense because there
is no open files there's no way
for white to use this long diagonal
the position is closed there's just no
pieces that could penetrate rapport's
position
so here
it's forgiven
otherwise if there's an open position
don't do it just don't do it okay
promises promises not doing it
not doing it
some heads shaken
okay
okay not gonna do it
right we're not gonna do it
good good all right so i
i've got some people it's on it's on
stream it's gonna be everywhere
so
we've got all the information that we
need you're gonna use this if you ever
play g5 again okay
all right good so g5 knight f3
not f6 and now the knight is going
towards that e4 square
so
even though it's a closed position you
still want to control the most important
squares
knight c1 knight e4 queen c2 knight d3
and even though we know who's winning
rapport is more well known than white
there is credit to be given for white's
play this plan of knight c1 knight d3
knight e5
is
very high class unfortunately for white
this won't change anything
but
he does get the control
of that critical square
rook c8 knight d3 h5
here and voila we are in this position
we've been here before say h4 takes here
here queen h6
knight takes queen takes h4
so there's a lot of footwork to get into
winning position it's not just boom boom
boom i'm going to win because i know how
to do
puzzle rush or any sort of tactics
i have to build up the position and then
my extra knowledge of tactics or puzzles
will help me out to win the game
f4
so
i'm stopping here because we still have
to ponder what's the best way to
continue as black
to take or not to take that is the
question
positional better than tactics
um just like any meme on the internet
both i think both
take and push g3
okay so
take this or push
now chess is a tough game
it's about kind of proving your point
you can say i want to play this i want
to play that
but as i said it before
it's all about the decision which one
you're going to do
i feel like you can get to 000 with
tactics but to push further than that
you have to have both exactly
that's why i'm showing that yes
rapport knows the flashy stuff but had
to build up the position first
c3
g3
okay
what will y do in case of g3
i see the threat
but will white have to resign after this
you already played g3
yeah i think
and unfortunately we don't have mate
anymore
it sacrifices itself and actually white
has enough space now to escape
and now we're actually lost so we had a
good position oh it's gone it's suddenly
gone
because white has a beautiful night soon
to have a safe king we can't really say
the same thing about our own
so it's never too late
to ruin something that was so great for
us
so he took he said okay
i'm just gonna take this
now
material wise it's still even however
this king on g1 is just too exposed
in c4
bishop takes e5
now a lot of times when we're getting a
winning position
there are a couple of things that we
always have to look for
any guesses what do we have to look out
for first
when you get a position that's
dominating
yeah god um
how not to ruin that position that is
correct but what do you mean by that
let's be a bit more specific
meanwhile chat is saying it
checks from your opponent counter play
okay
but these are a little bit uh
too broad
forcing moves
from us
from our opponent exactly
so the first thing you should be looking
for yes you're the one who should be
winning the game you already build up
the position you should be winning
but
every move they make every step they
take you have to be watching what
they're trying to do to you
and right here
this is a glaring threat so if we would
go like ha ha
you're gonna get mated
well
got bad news
we're gonna be the one getting mated
it's so easy to lose in chess if you're
not paying attention to your opponent's
threats
and believe it or not
even the best of the best sometimes say
oh my goodness i'm winning i'm
objectively the better player hooray for
me
and they still fall for
cheap tricks
so here
bishop takes e5 is a strong move by
richie he says no fun for you
all fun for me
takes
g3 now g3 coast is clear you look around
and that's actually the reason
most of the gm's go hmm
any threats for you any no more threat
no more threats for
you let's go g3
no more queen f7 shenanigans
i'm happy with my position let's go on
in
king f1
now
apart from threats you still want to
understand
the plan the underlying plan of your
opponent
what do you think is julie trying to do
now
yes the king wants to go escape it wants
to flee away from that danger zone
so richie says not ah
you ain't going nowhere
you ain't passing through sir
you're here to stay
in g1
so
that attempt of fleeing has been stopped
so
you just have to get the finishing
touches in
i think you should there to double up
the flips
that would take too much time you could
just develop a plan already
i mean
okay so it's always beneficial
to think about sequences
you
give
the best move the move that you consider
the best and then you look for a move
for your opponent
and i know that's kind of the most
tedious part oh go ahead
by the way don't be sh don't be shy
you mean rook h1 here
okay i capture
and then
play um
[Music]
okay king won back
[Music]
so here it takes
here here
oh um
[Music]
we'll see if this king will escape
before it has to go to the hospital
it seems to be escaping right yeah
because we check here
here
we take
king d1 and
it has runeth away
from all the danger
and uh it's going to start a new life on
the queen side
probably with a new family
and a new identity too
it's not the same king anymore it's a
king that is freed from all the dangers
so back we go
back we go in this case
so one of the hardest part in chess
is to get out of the mindset of focusing
on your own moves okay you want a double
but what do you think is your opponent
going to do
in that case
probably
but that's not the only way to play
ray robson's saying this almost gives
soupy curls and
vibes yes
not really but yes
kind of
but this actually preceded that one
so
yeah yes and no maybe
kind of
yeah i'd say yes
rook h2 and
here white said thank you so much i had
enough fun here
uh king f1 then there's mate
but what if white goes
queen c5
yeah it's a similar pattern yes that rey
is correct it has a similar pattern
so what is white trying to do
oh so rey is saying
rey was uh hoping
for this trick
queen f3 check
which is cute but unfortunately doesn't
work
although here
now this is completely unnecessary but
beautiful queen f3 takes takes there's
mate
king g1 rook here
yes
yes
quite pretty because the only check you
have is on f7 but i capture
so rook h2 queen c5 there's this last
thing that we have to solve this is
important
it's just a single step away and we go
hooray
we win
i mean and the previous one was wasn't
too ugly either we would have also gone
hooray we created a brilliancy
yeah
can you have seven
and if i
check your
[Music]
well
this hard part about chess is that
nobody will tell you that your opponent
won't go like yes you are winning in
five moves please find it i'd be honored
you'll have to figure it out on your own
so there are competing ideas this is one
and this is the other one
so what's the sequence you take
and
then okay
and then
[Music]
oh that that'd be not good
that'd be not good
but the queen after is a little better
yes
here
um
okay so here
wow although this is also just a simple
one but of course this is very stylish
now
if you see a simple mate always choose
the simple mate because you may miss
something
so if you see this is a simple checkmate
don't get too fancy
because there are times when people
realize oh it spins so i actually can't
move that one oh i'm not winning it no
more i'm losing
so um
rook takes g2 is very elegant
but kudos for all of you saying queen h4
and there are occasions
plenty of moments where rogue g2 wins
you the game however there's always this
involved risk what if you miscalculate
it
you don't want to do that
so all of you played queen h4
laparoony for you
because you said well you're trying my
opponent is trying to go queen e7
and we go na ah
and we'll be there to stop that
meanwhile our attack is still raging
so really what i wanted
to
show you guys that yes a ton of times
you go on
and find the right solution but first
off you have to build it up and of
course we'll put on this position there
too
after rook h2 by the way and this
position
here julie resigned
and richie won
but uh let's end it on the note you
could also have two queens
but not at all necessary
and it's checkmate
so what did we learn from
this game by report
we learned
that a
you'll have to build up your attack
b
you may be able to
throw all the pawns in front of your
king only if the position is closed
and
c you always
have to look for your opponent's threats